good morning believe nation today's
message is be proud of your work over to
you Amitabh Bachchan I doubt if there's
any actor in the entire world with all
due respect to mr. DeNiro when they
haven't gone ahead and done a film and
it hasn't turned out to be you know the
the kind of film that they they believed
it would be or it has been so incredibly
bad that yeah it's just kind of
forgotten in their vision sometimes we
do films because we believe in the
person who is going to make it sometimes
it's a gesture sometimes it's your own
belief going wrong we all make mistakes
and if they were mistakes fine but I
will not derive any film that I have
done I will stay with every film that I
have made and I will say that I had a
great time making them irrespective of
what happened at the box office I think
there's a real danger in judging the
success of your work only by the results
that it gets you know we've talked a lot
about this on the channel that it's not
just about the outcome it's not just
about the goal it's about the process
that how you get there is way more
important than the fact that you got
there and I think again a lot of people
think that because they put a lot of
work into something but it doesn't get
that success that they're looking for
that it was a failure where if I look at
myself as an example my goals have an
impact I want you guys to watch these
videos and more importantly I want you
guys to take action on them I want you
to feel touched and moved and inspired
by something that's been said in one of
these videos and go and do something
about it make the world better in some
small or big way because of watching
these videos that's my goal all the time
and so yes I look at the numbers and yes
I want hit to hit a million subscribers
and yes I want everybody to take off and
be amazing but if it doesn't it doesn't
take away from the
and appreciation and love that I put
into each video that I make so as an
example the the Tyrese Gibson top ten
video that I made recently I did a good
chunk of that video myself it's the most
that I've ever put into a top ten video
and I've talked about that before in the
channel the most work that I personally
ever put in to a top ten video and I
badly wanted it to do Wow right I mean
here it is I put all this work in I hope
you guys love but it sucks to feel like
I put this out there and you guys don't
appreciate it doesn't miss doesn't have
its mark I felt deeply moved by and I
was hoping you guys would be as well it
turns out the video hasn't done well and
that that's great but even if the video
didn't do well even if people didn't
like even if it only had five views on
the video I would be sad but also at the
same time I would know that I put a lot
of love into it and it's still a really
valuable video and that I'd learned in
the process of making this video I grew
as a human being and as an entrepreneur
and I'm still deeply proud of the video
that I made regardless of how while it
went on for you guys people to watch and
see success with and so I think there's
a real danger and just chasing the
numbers and just being obsessed with
reaching the goal and not caring about
the process where in fact the process is
way way way way way more important if
you do not love the process of what
you're doing you won't get to those
numbers if you focus only on the numbers
you're never gonna get there you have to
love the doing and be proud of your work
so the question today today is I'm
curious are you deeply insanely proud of
the work that you're doing right now in
your company be honest leave it down the
count's below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourselves and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events
expresso keep me going